はい、ではですね、次に皆さんのAIエージェントの能力というのを文字通り無限に広げていく鍵となるのが、このパートで学ぶAPIとHTTPリクエストになります。
AIエージェントの能力を無限に広げる鍵、APIとHTTPリクエストをしっかりと理解すること、n8nに専用ツールがないサービス、例えば社内サービスだったりとか、社内システム、最新のAIとかと連携させる魔法の道具、HTTPリクエスト、ノードというのをマスターする、そんなパートにできたらと思います。
はいみなさんこれまでGmailだったりWikipediaといったすでにn8nにある専用ツール、公式ツールみたいなのを使ってきましたよね。
ここでこう調べてたくさん出てくるもの。これらは基本的にn8n側がもうすでに用意してくれているブロック、ノードになります。
しかしですね、世の中にはこういった専用ツールがまだ用意されていないサービス、特定の業界の業務システムであったりとか、最新、出たばっかりの最新のAIサービスとか、あとは皆さんの社内で使っている独自のツールとかっていうのが山ほどあります。
そういったあらゆるサービスと接続するために使うのが、今回学ぶHTTPリクエストノードになります。
これさえマスターしちゃえば、皆さんはWeb上のあらゆるサービスと自由に連携させる力っていうのを手に入れることができますよというところですね。
先ほどHTTPリクエストともう一つAPIというのを話したんですけども、そんなAPIなんですかというところで、HTTPリクエストに何を書けばいいかを知るためにその前提となるAPIですね、についてお話ししたいと思います。
APIとはアプリケーションプログラミングインターフェースと書いて、それの略なんですけども、こう聞くとちょっと難しそうと思うかもしれないんですけど、全然こう難しく考えなくて大丈夫です。
言ってしまえば、アプリケーションAとアプリケーションBという2つ、普通だったら繋がらないものを連携させるのがAPIになりますよというところですね。
例えば、お客様がいて、レストランですね。お客様がいて、キッチンがいますよ、というところで、ウェイターさん、ホールみたいな動きですね。
お客様は注文をまずウェイターに伝えます。
そのウェイターはお客様の注文をキッチンに伝えて料理を受け取ります。
その後、API、ウェイターはお客様に料理を提供するというところで、お客様のリクエストをキッチンに伝えて、APIの処理してレスポンスをすると、みたいな流れですね。
こんな感じで、プログラム同士が接続するためのルールのことになります。
Credentialのパートで使ったAPIキーというものは、そんな互いのルールの簡易証であったりとか、二分証明書みたいなところになります。
このサービスにしっかりとお金を払っている正規のユーザーですよと証明するための大事な鍵みたいなものですね。
みたいなところで、APIというのがなんとなく理解できたと思うので、次にHTTPリクエストというところに入りたいと思います。
HTTPリクエストのノードというのは、これら外部のサービスのAPIと接続するための自由度の高いノードになります。
自分でその内容の仕組みとかっていうのを作れるノードになります。 専用ツールではn8nと接続するための設定というのがもうすでにこの中に入っているんですね。
なんですけども、HTTPリクエストノードではこの設定を自分たち、私たちが自分で書く必要がありますよというところですね。
先ほども言ったように、特定の業界でしか使わない業務システムであったり、最新、もう出たばっかりのAIサービスとか社内ツールとか専用ツールがないから、このn8n使えないんじゃないかなっていうところで諦める必要はないですよと。
このHTTPリクエストをマスターしちゃえば、皆さんのAIエージェントの可能性っていうのは、本当に文字通り無限大に広がりますよというところですね。
では早速HTTPリクエストを使っていきたいと思います。
プラスからHTTPリクエストと調べると、こんな感じでHTTPリクエストが出てきます。
今回はこちらの下の部分を使います。
この中身を設定するためにまず必要になるツールです。
今回練習題としてTavilyというWebリサーチツールっていうのを使いたいと思います。
このTavilyですね、Googleで調べていただくとこんな感じで出てきます。
これですね。このTavilyどういうサイトなのかというと、一言で言うとAIによって強化されたGoogleみたいなもので
AIが検索をかけてくれるような、非常に賢くインターネットの情報を調べてまとめてくれるサービスになります。
しかもこのサービスですね、毎月1000クレジットっていうクレジット制なんですけども、クレジットまで無料で使えますよとなっているので、今回こちらを使ってやっていきたいなと思います。
Tavilyのページを開いたら、まずですね、多分使ったことある方なかなかいないかなと思うので、右上の部分からSign upを押していただくと、通常であればGoogleでログインとかっていうのが出てくると思うので、そちらでログインしてください。
ログインの手順というのは、OpenRouterの時とほぼ同じなので、簡単にできるかなと思います。
登録が完了したらまずやることとしては サイト上に表示されているここですね
APIキーっていうのを作る必要があります ここにすでに一個作ってあるんですけども
ここのプラスからKey Nameは 今回n8nでもとかでいいので
こんな感じで作っていただいて でクリエイトを押します
するとこんな感じで出てくるのでこれがAPIキーですね 今これ隠されちゃってるのでここから表示をさせてコピーしますよと
これここを押したらコピーされますしここの四角を押してもコピーされるのでコピーして 大事に保管しておいてください
はい、では次のステップに入ります。 このTavilyのAPIキーというのが取得できました。
次に必要なのはこのTavilyとn8nを接続するための設定になります。
はい、n8n戻っていただいて、このHTTPリクエストっていうのに何を書けばいいのか。
この内容をどういうふうに書けばいいのかわからないってなってしまいます。
その書き方を教えてくれるのがこのTavilyのドキュメントというのにあります。
ここの部分ですね。この右の左のドキュメント。 ここを開いてみるとこんなページが出てきます。
これ開発者向けに書かれているものなので、ちょっと一見見てみると、全部英語っていうのもありますし、かなりちょっと難しそうに見えると思うんですけども、僕たちが探すべきものはたった一つだけになります。
その名もcURLと呼ばれるものですね。小文字のCに大文字のURLでcURLと言うんですけども、このcURL何かというと、APIを接続するための設定内容が書かれているコードみたいなものですね。
これをコピーできれば、どんなに専門知識がなくても、その注文に必要な情報が一気に手に入ってしまいます。
先ほどのTavilyのドキュメントを開くと、こんな画面になるので、ここでこのcURLを探していきたいと思います。
このTavilyに関しては、クイックスタートですね。ここを押していただいて、この下の方にピューピューピューと行っていくと、こんな感じで、Python、JavaScript、これですね、cURLと書いてあるので、これを選びます。
すると、こんな感じでコードが出てくるんですけども、これが基本的なcURLの構成になっております。
まずここのポストという部分ですね。これはリクエストの内容、何かをお願いするものなのか、何かを受け取るものなのかですね。
ちょっとスライドを使うと、こんな感じ、クライアントとサーバーがあったとして、データの取得をするのがGet、データの送信とか作成をするのがPostですね。
今回はこのTavilyでデータを作ったものを送信するのでPOSTというのがここに書いてあります。
その下、ここですね。httpsのこのリンクみたいなもの、URLっていうのが
接続先のリンク、リクエストを送る宛先になります。
その下、ここ。ここは補足情報みたいなところで、APIキー、あなたの会員証はこれです、自分の会員証はこれです、といった補足情報を載せるものになります。
そして、ここのDという部分に関しては、具体的なリクエスト内容ですね。
Tavilyに何を調べてほしいか、TavilyAIで強化されたGoogleというふうにお伝えしたので、何を調べてほしいかという具体的なお願い、プロンプトみたいなのを書く場所になります。
このcURL見つけられたら、右上からコピーを押して、n8nのキャンバスに戻って、このHTTPリクエストノードを開くと、
いろいろ自分で設定をしないといけないかなとかあると思うんですけど、ここを見てみると、Import cURLというのが出てきます。
ここにPaste the cURL command hereと書いてあるので、これをコピペ、先ほどのコピーしたやつをペーストしてインポートを押すと、こんな感じでもう全部一気に設定をしてくれるんですね。
めちゃくちゃ難しい難解な呪文みたいなものが自動で伝票に書かれたみたいな感じですね。
こんな感じで、n8n、公式が出しているもの以外の外部サービスと連携する際には、まずはドキュメントを見つける、ドキュメントを見つけて、cURLを見つける、この2点がむちゃくちゃ大事になりますよというところですね。
入力されたここを見てみると、まずヘッダーのバリューを見ると、TavilyのYour API Keyという感じになっております。
このYour API Keyの部分を先ほどTavilyで用意したこのAPIキーをコピペします。
これをペーストします。
Tavilyのここの部分ですね。ここをペースト。この部分は残して半角開けて、その後にAPIキーを入力みたいな形です。
その次、下のボディのところを見てみると、ここに何を書きますか?っていう
今ここメッシのメッシは誰ですかみたいな感じで書いてあるんですけども、ここにプロンプトみたいなのをやります。
今回試しに、こうですね。
今日のAIニュースについて詳しく教えてみたいな感じのプロンプトにしたいと思います。
この際に忘れがちなのが、ここのダブルクオーテーションっていうちょんちょんがあるもの。
これで囲むっていうのを忘れずにやってください。
これができたら、ノード単体これで1回実行ですね。
この実行を押してみると、はい、このアウトプットの部分にTavilyが調べてくれた結果が返ってきてたら大成功になります。
命令が今日のAIニュースについて教えてというものだったと思うんですけども、
それが出てきたのがこんな感じですね。一気にChatGPTのモデルの性能比較みたいなのが一気にこんな感じで出てきております。
これが出てきたら成功になります。
もしですね、なんかここでエラーが出ているとか、うまくいかないなーっていう時は、私たちのフレームワークっていうのをまず思い出してください。
こういうエラーが出たってなったら、ChatGPTだったり、Google AI Studioですね、の出番になりますよと。
じゃあ先ほど、これがなくて、エラーが出ましたよとなった時とか、他ですね、じゃあここの
このAPIキーがないでエラーが出る時とかっていうのはここに大体エラーの理由であったりとかっていうのが出てきます。
そしたらこのエラーコードをコピーして ワークフロー全体のJSONコードというのをこの右上からダウンロードして
ダウンロードしたものっていうのをChatGPTとかGoogle AI Studioにアップロードして
〇〇こうこうこういうところでエラーになってしまっています。 これを修正したいですみたいな感じで言うと
しっかりAIがトラブルシューティングみたいな感じでやってくれるので エラーが出たらまずAIに聞いてみるっていうのを習慣づけるようにしてください
はい、接続ができたら、ここの先ほど今日のAIニュースについて詳しく教えてと直接書いていたものを、こっちのチャットで書いたものとして認識してほしいので、
それはどういうものになるかというと、このように書きます。
クエリ、JSONのチャットインプット、チャットで書いたものをここに反映させるよというところで設定をします。
それができたら、ここのチャットに対して、チャットにこんな感じで、今日のAIニュースについて教えてと言ってやってみると、
こんな感じでこのチャットで出てきました。今日のAIニュースについて教えてというと、本日最新の具体的なAIニュースの情報は厳しい情報ですが、最近注目されているAIの話題としては以下のものですというところで、こんな感じで詳しく調べたのを出してくれました。
例えば、こういったように、Tavilyという公式のノードがなかったとしても、このHTTPリクエストという白紙の注文伝票みたいなところにTavilyのcURLというのを入力すると、公式として出していないけども、しっかり外部のサービスを連携させることができますよというところですね。
もう皆さんがn8nに専用のツールないなーっていうところで諦める必要が一切ないですよというところですね。
こう作れるAIエージェントの可能性というのが今日このパートでもう文字通り無限大に広がりましたよというところで
APIとHTTPリクエスト、あとはcURLっていうのをしっかり覚えておいてください。